all right
thank you
thank you while flights nearly Collide
the airports won't let you sleep inside
it's true even Stars experience pain
when they dare to travel by plane
married Hollywood stars they do exist
Dax Shepard and Kristen Bell along with
their two kids were kicked out of the
Boston airport for trying to sleep at
the gate airport authorities deny it had
anything to do with how awful their
movies are
[Laughter]
the flight was delayed nine hours into
the next day in every Hotel within 50
miles was booked so they decided to
spend the night they spent 600 bucks on
blankets and sheets sheets at the
airport and pillows geez for that price
they could have bought four bottled
waters
Total Airport joke but 600 bucks come on
haven't they heard of other reasonably
priced products
there are no my pillow outlets at the
airport I find that kind of sinister
well anyway after the airport kicked him
out they found their way to a friend of
a friend's house that's mysterious at
1am the lesson I'm glad I only travel by
Big Wheel
meanwhile in Florida an Allegiant which
I've never heard of plane was almost hit
by a private jet and it wasn't mine
passengers were so distraught they
actually stopped beating the crap out of
each other
one passenger said the plane had to take
immediate evasive action and climb 600
feet to avoid a mid-air Collision sounds
like interns at The View when Joy Behar
is coming down the hall
[Applause]
flight attendant was reportedly heard
and the plane had to return to its
takeoff airport passengers knew
something was amiss when the captain
illuminated the holy sign
good I'm glad you did that
[Applause]
we should spell out all our swear words
that is such a good
[Music]
idea anyway Chris uh you you're
intellectual I believe you're you put
the man in Manhattan Institute
um
I'm breaking him in slow
um what are we doing what's going wrong
here can we blame it all on mayor Pete
uh yeah I think we should but I think
what's happening is part of its broader
process we see a continual erosion of
the standard of living in this country
right you have rolling electrical
brackets you have airports in chaos you
have state after State now abolishing
standardized tests we're lowering our
Horizons we're substituting ideology
like diversity equity and inclusion but
the people are starting to feel that
it's no substitute for excellence Merit
actually building things that work and I
think that if this continues it's going
to be ripe ground for a politician to
come and exploit people's frustration
the quality goes down and the price goes
up is typically the conditions for
getting someone that has the the stones
that it's going to require to make some
real changes in our country yeah you
know
could you put a camera on Chris Ruffo
for a second Tyrus doesn't he look like
he would be Paulie Shore's more
successful brother
yeah yeah yeah I don't know why I just
get him and I see Paulie Shore got his
act cleaned up you travel probably more
than anybody here unfortunately yes so
is it it's obvious question is it
getting better or worse but it's you
know what I think it's funny that the
people that went out and actually bought
blankets and pillows had to go yeah
because they stayed at the gate but if
they would just go lay in the doorway
when you walk in yeah
[Applause]
and it's hot out too it's hot it's like
heated in the winter I guess it's either
summertime you just it's a sauna but uh
that's frustrating because the airlines
they you don't do that you have a now
they're lucky because they're
celebrities and they went on Instagram
and said hey anybody want to put up
celebrities kids for tonight and I'm
sure they got people but regular John
and Joe taxpayer would be stuck in an
airport with no hotels with small
children in the airport basically said
sorry you have to leave now that's
terrible and that's a reflection of what
frustrated people they don't have any
backup plans and they love to use the
excuse Act of God but since they don't
believe in God shouldn't we have to
change that yeah like you know because
it's always we're not responsible for
getting you a hotel room listen to act
of God yeah well he's not allowed in our
churches and schools anymore in our
airports and if you sing pledge
allegiance to the United States like so
shouldn't active God be gone and now
it's just active airport active mayor
Pete active mayor Pete
shouldn't they be responsible that's
that's what sucks is that it's only
convenient when a convenient for them
yeah I think it's a shame that they had
to leave they weren't hurting anybody at
the gate and clearly they yeah they did
the right thing they had got blankets
and stuff so shame on them for that
because the alternative is to walking
out with the street of Boston yeah you
know cat uh what kind of world would you
want to live in this world if Mr and Mrs
Kristen Bell are treated like Riff Raff
I mean on the ladder of celebrity I mean
we are above them let's be honest but I
mean but they're gonna treat if they're
gonna treat our nation's married
celebrities like this what hope is there
for single celebrities like Pauly Shore
wow wow
I feel like you don't have to answer
yeah this is not a courtroom and you're
not her lawyer no actually he is
um oh I'm so worried I have an unpopular
opinion but that's never stopped me
before
um okay if you'll know I don't know if
they were kicked out for sleeping at the
airport they might have been kicked out
for like building infrastructure at the
airport
because you can get away with sleeping
in the airport if you don't make a big
deal about it this was clearly about the
production and and again I know this
might be offensive to say because you
know I don't have children therefore I
know nothing about the world but
I do know that she's not brushing her
teeth there yeah she's nowhere near a
sink yeah she's walking around the
airport with a toothbrush in her mouth
like like look at me I have to brush my
teeth at the airport it's like you're
you're influencing so maybe they were
kicked out for aggressive influencing I
would like that and not for sleeping at
the airport because you can sleep at the
airport if you're kind of just like a
little Gremlin there yeah
like me
um but yeah and again but I don't know
what it's like to have kids so it's
probably harder to be like shut up be a
gremlin to a to a child yeah but that's
probably why they were kicked out that's
why you drug them right Michelle
drugging children uh it's not something
I endorse but if I had kids oh look out
drugs because back in the day your
grandmother would do that yeah
sip of the whiskey whiskey they put a
little something in your bottle if you
were a colicky or whatever you know
knock you right out exactly uh not that
I condone that no not at all I don't I
think they probably got kicked out
because I think there are a certain
number of hours in the airport where
people the public isn't allowed I don't
know that for sure yeah but here's what
I'll say and I'll uh dovetail off poly
Shore over here is that
is that we have what's wrong with like
being excellent and having really good
really high standards yeah what's wrong
with living in nice pretty surroundings
with clean airports and flights that
don't crash what's wrong with this it
seems like there's a certain portion of
society way over on the left that feels
so guilty about it because not everyone
in the world can do that yeah so we have
to that we have to lower ours in order
to make everything fair so rather than
be aspirational and inspirational and
say this is what can be we're we've
started to just impose this no no we
can't be better than everyone else we
have to be as low as everybody else so
we're not going to worry about flights
we're not going to airports we're not
going to clean people out in New York in
the streets parts of the streets you go
down you go what in the hell is that
scent
well maybe it was you I got some I got
some
I was
a set job apologize don't apologize
I have an active bladder but you know
and trash bags all over like why do
people accept this as oh you're right
one word Equity yeah lower hiring people
based on how they look instead of lower
the standards and everything goes Equity
is another term for lower standards yes
there you go that should be on a t-shirt
like this where it says nothing is
possible
all right
up next award-winning hair and a dress
with flair hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else